>>Male Presenter: And a hush fell on the crowd.
[laughter]
So, welcome. Welcome. Thank you for hanging
on for us. Welcome to "Thank God it's Wednesday
Kitchen." I'm very excited. This is my kitchen.
We've had it brought in specially from Teddington.
And welcome to the Optimize Your Life event.
You've heard about Optimize Your Life?
You know what we're trying to do with this?
We're trying to make Googlers the happiest
and healthiest people at any company in the
world. And we've got a big task in our hands.
So let's go for it. Yay.
>>Audience: Yay!
OK. So, this is an event from the Food Team
in London. We love our food team and Adrian.
Cheer for Adrian and the Food Team.
[audience cheers]
And from the London Events Team. So welcome
to all of you in the room. We're also live
in 20 other locations around Europe, from
Aarhus to Zürich, from Accra
in Ghana to Stockholm, Dublin, Madrid, Copenhagen,
and all the usual suspects.
So, welcome to everybody on the TV. Now what
you want is obviously for me to get out of
the way, 'cause this is a really special event.
You can see from the atmosphere in the room
just how much the excitement is here. Uh,
hello. Someone just got a call. One of Jamie's
crew's got a call, so, are you done?
>>Crew Member: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: OK, perfect.
[laughter]
So, today is all about the food side of things
and I'm really excited. Google started in
1999. And in 1999 is when the Naked Chef started,
too. So Jamie and Google have grown up a phenomenal
rate. Both of us have got big ambitions and
Jamie's an amazing guy.
Started at a pub, his parent's pub in the
pub kitchen, became the Naked Chef, practicing--.
Left school at 16. Left school at 16, no qualifications,
went to catering college, then Carluccio's
then The River Cafe. Best-selling cookbooks,
Fifteen Foundation, campaigning for healthy
food for school kids, taking on the food industry
in the US. This is one amazing guy. Ladies
and gentlemen, Jamie Oliver.
[audience cheers]
>>Jamie Oliver: Hello. My God, there's a lot
of you. Cheers, brother, . Ah, the future
of England is in this room. My God. Thank
you. All of a sudden I feel very popular.
That's wonderful. You never know if anyone's
gonna turn up. Thank you very much. It's a
real pleasure to be here.
>>Male Presenter: Well, Jamie, welcome to
Google. What do you make of it?
>>Jamie Oliver: So far, so good. Lots of creative
thinking places. Lots of cool words. Lots
of lovely-looking people. And as you all know,
you're very important in today's society.
You guys are the future of spreading things
around and all that sort of business.
[laughter]
I'm feeling a bit dated and old-fashioned
really, but we'll do a bit of cooking anyway.
>>Male Presenter: Like I say that, the future
of spreading things around. I think we might
change our slogan to that.
[laughter]
>>Jamie Oliver: I think it, yeah. I do think--.
Look, I come from a campaign in the last eight
years I've dedicated to campaigning. And all
of you guys, the digital world, blogging communities,
it's so important now and getting feedback
from people straight away, getting support,
signing petitions.
Basically, I mean my job--well part of my
job--which I'm very good at is being a pain
in the ass and an agitator. So, you guys make
me better at that. So, thank you.
>>Male Presenter: So, Jamie, before we get
started, there was one thing I wanted to ask
you 'cause I noticed that you really started
out with a bit of a profile in 1999, which
is really the time that Google started.
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: And you've taken on some
big challenges in your life--
>>Jamie Oliver: Yes.
>>Male Presenter: and have really tried to
change the world and that's some of the things
that we'd like to do as well. What is it that
motivates you? What is it that took you from
dropping out of school at 16 to taking on
the world's food industry?
>>Jamie Oliver: I just--. I'm a big believer.
I just love food. I love what food does. I
think it's a wonderful leveler. I think it
brings people together. I've always found
food a wonderful excuse to bring people together
and have a good laugh, basically. For me,
personally, at school I was a really bad achiever.
I was a special needs kid. I never had an
opportunity at school to shine. But then through
cooking, touching, feeling, tasting, being
able to create things, I found that I wasn't
bloody useless. Actually, I could be half
decent. And also, when I got out in the big
wide world, I realized there was lots of other
people like me as well.
So, I'm very biased. I think life is short.
You eat three times a day. When I talk to
kids in schools and stuff, you sort of say,
"Look, it's about being streetwise." If I
can get you to budget and save money and be
able to knock-out a quick meal in 10 minutes,
20 minutes, 30 minutes, a lovely Sunday roast,
birthday cakes.
If I can make your life taste better, if you
can have more fun doing it, if you can look
good, if I can get you laid, if I can save
you some money--
[laughter]
But it's true. It's true. Girls, come on.
If a fellow can cook, is that not better or
what?
>>Female Audience Members: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: I mean, if he was a bit of
a crap shag, you might say, "Well, he can
cook, though." You know what I mean?
[laughter]
So, you balance it out.
[applause]
But this isn't quite going the way you wanted
it, was it?
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: You're spreading it around.
>>Jamie Oliver: But when you can say to someone,
"Look, at the end of the day the second biggest
bill of your life will be the money you spend
in a supermarket. And I think it's every £10
spent in this country, £2 goes to Tesco's."
If you put it in perspective.
So, I think if you can make people ten percent
more efficient at buying, not waste--. Forty
percent of what we buy gets wasted. So for
me, if you look at life, you can save hundreds
of thousands of pounds and I'm sure you can
find good things to do with that.
>>Male Presenter: OK, good. OK Jamie, I think
what we would like to do is we've had some
great video entries for the competition--
>>Jamie Oliver: Yes.
>>Male Presenter: to win a prize, which is
cooking right here right now with you.
>>Jamie Oliver: Right.
>>Male Presenter: OK. And our judges have
been in operation. And what we're gonna do
is we've got all of our entrants sitting in
the front row. So, we're waiting to announce
the winner. The winner will come up and cook
with you for a bit.
>>Jamie Oliver: Lovely.
>>Male Presenter: Which will be great.
>>Jamie Oliver: I have jobs. Many jobs.
>>Male Presenter: And then also, ladies and
gentlemen, Jamie is gonna do his live webcast
from here as well this evening at 6:30. So
you're welcome to stay on for that if you
want to. But we're gonna do some live cooking
right now. So, it's tense. We've seen all
the videos.
>>Jamie Oliver: Do we get to see them, or
have you already been through?
>>Male Presenter: We've been watching them
for the last half hour or so. So, we're all
very familiar.
>>Jamie Oliver: Oh, so you've done those.
OK.
>>Male Presenter: OK, so the winner of the
Cook With Jamie competition impressed us the
most with her authentic pasta in one pan.
It's Maria Barrera from the development team.
[audience cheers]
Come on up, Maria. Come on up.
>>Jamie Oliver: There she is.
[audience claps]
Maria. Congratulations. Welcome to the one--.
Are you Italian? Fantastico.
[laughter]
Bloody great. You could've picked me someone
that wasn't Italian.
[laughter]
Ciao.
>>Maria: Nice to meet you.
>>Jamie Oliver: Tutto bene?
>>Maria: Si.
>>Jamie Oliver: Fantastico. OK. Where are
you from in Italy?
>>Maria: I'm from a very small city west of
Rome.
>>Jamie Oliver: Nice.
>>Maria: It's about two hours from Rome. The
city's so small, so.
>>Jamie Oliver: Lovely.
>>Maria: I'm from Campobasso.
>>Jamie Oliver: Campobasso? Near Farfa?
>>Maria: Near Farfa?
>>Jamie Oliver: Mmm.
>>Maria: Umm, no.
>>Jamie Oliver: Have you noticed all of a
sudden I've gone quite camp.
[laughter]
OK. Come on in, Tiger. We're gonna make some
pasta. I got this for my birthday. So I thought
we'd go through this. It will add no relevance
to your life. But I thought it might be nice
to see a gadget. So we've been playing with
it for a couple of weeks.
Tiger, look at that. This is an original.
One of the first patented pasta machines.
I've also got two pasta machines I'm gonna
give away as prizes to some lovely people
with your gain today. But what we're gonna
do is we're gonna, me and you as a united
front, we're gonna get this room excited about
pasta.
>>Maria: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: Now as you know, you've got
two types of pasta really. You got from the
South you have more of a flour and water,
or semolina and water. So, that's your al
dente pasta. And being generalistic, that's
more olive oil and seafood and al dente and
stuff like that.
And then, we've got the more Northern style,
which is egg and flour. This is what we're
gonna do today. So, it's really, really simple.
We can do it by hand in a bowl, or we can
just whack it in here. So, we've got--. Is
this 200 grams we've got in here? To one person,
a hundred grams of flour. I mean, you can
see I'm looking a little bit phased now 'cause
I never weigh it. Do you make-a the pasta?
Do you make pasta?
[laughter]
>>Maria: Sometimes.
>>Jamie Oliver: Sometimes. So, we got a hundred
grams of flour there. One egg, Tiger. We have
a little pulse up. We're gonna get this going.
Now remember, in a bowl you can do this literally
just by knocking stuff together. You're just
making Play-Doh.
It's so simple. And it's a beautiful thing
to make. And I'll tell you why, pasta, you
can see it coming together. It almost starts
to clean the bowl. We've really done nothing.
I mean, I quite like this. It's a timing thing.
When you get home from work, you just go crack,
crack, handful, handful, buzz, buzz. Put a
pan on.
Get the kettle on. Get it out. You get the
little--. I'll have my pasta with cheese set
up all the time. [imitates food processor]
Nice. So, but look. For me personally, as
a non-academic person, it was a real moment
for me when you took something as humble as
egg and flour--really, really cheap things,
right? And then you put them together and
you make Play-Doh.
And then you can flavor it. You can color
it. You can put pepper in it. You can put
herbs in it. You can pound up basil. It can
go green. You can get mushrooms, whiz 'em
up and make them go brown. You can put the
squid ink in it. You can change all these
colors and then you can make all these different
shapes. Tagliatelle, tagliolini, pappardelle,
come on, give them some names.
>>Maria: Penne. Rigatoni.
>>Jamie Oliver: Penne. Rigatoni.
>>Maria: Mezzani, orecchiette, fusilli.
>>Jamie Oliver: Fusilli, as you can see.
[laughter]
So, it goes on and on. For me, this was like
freedom. It's freedom. And what it meant was
I can be creative and it meant I think, without
getting too soppy, the beauty of moving on
with life and cracking on is about confidence,
self-esteem, and feeling good about yourself.
And when you're told you're shit all the time,
when you get this little bad boy and actually
you can knock out tagliatelle, pappardelle,
ling--, some beautiful fettuccine. You stuff
and oh, like good. So, it's a little, for
me and I'm saying to you, it's a little bubble
of control and expertise that makes you feel
good about stuff.
So, what we're gonna do is we've got our pasta
coming together here. Dead simple. And we're
gonna make our pasta. We're gonna put it through
this ridiculous machine here. Now, if you
wanna sit on our--.
>>Maria: Me?
[laughter]
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah, of course. You won the
competition.
>>Maria: You sure it's not gonna break?
>>Jamie Oliver: Huh?
>>Maria: Are you sure it's not gonna break?
>>Jamie Oliver: No, no. You're in good nick,
darling. You'll be all right.
[laughter]
>>Maria: You want me to sit here?
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah, of course.
>>Maria: OK.
>>Jamie Oliver: Well you can do a handstand
if you want.
[laughter]
So, listen. What we're gonna do is we're gonna
extrude this pasta, OK? So we're gonna put
this through there. Now, so kind of put it
in perspective. And you can basically wind
it down and as it starts to come out, my darling,
as it pushes the pasta out, you can cut it
into lengths like that.
There's a sharp knife. Be careful. I'll leave
a little flour here. Now, the other thing
is to be really simplistic about it. Crack
one egg. Handful of flour. Mix it up. When
it comes together, use a full wine bottle
and just take little nuggets out. Roll it
out. It takes seconds. You don't need this
kit. You don't even need a pasta machine.
Roll it out. You can go as thin as you can.
And then you can roll it up with a bit of
flour. Slice it up. And you've got beautiful,
rustic pasta. So here we go here.
>>Male Helper: Nothing's come out yet.
>>Maria: It's hard though.
>>Jamie Oliver: It will do. It will do.
>>Male Helper: How long do you want it?
>>Jamie Oliver: What? How's it going? Have
you got--? Do you mind if I?
>>Maria: Please.
>>Jamie Oliver: Keep going, Tiger. Go on.
>>Maria: More?
>>Jamie Oliver: Go on, push. A bit harder.
[laughter]
Go on.
>>Maria: Get this machine.
>>Jamie Oliver: It's coming out. Give it a
cut now. Don't worry.
>>Male Helper: Can I cut now?
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah, don't be nervous.
>>Male Helper: All right. All right. Get it
all out. That's about right.
>>Jamie Oliver: It's all right. Go on.
>>Maria: Wow. I'm not going to the gym tonight.
>>Jamie Oliver: All right.
>>Male Helper: I think it says you're riding
side-saddle.
>>Jamie Oliver: Keep going. Keep going up.
OK. A bit longer. A bit faster. Can you go
a bit faster?
[laughter]
>>Maria: I will try.
>>Male Helper: Here we go. Another one. Let
me get it.
>>Jamie Oliver: There you go. And if you toss
that in pasta, we've got a lovely tagliatelle.
I'll tell you what--.
>>Male Helper: I think we screwed this right
up.
[laughter]
>>Jamie Oliver: Bring it out. We'll put some
more flour in it and we'll have another go.
We've got pasta. Push it all out. I think
it's a little bit soft. If you mix up some
of that flour into it, just make it a bit
firmer and put it through again, we'll be
in a good place.
>>Maria: Sorry
>>Jamie Oliver: Now, that only takes 45 seconds
to cook, OK? So, I thought we'd make a really
quick summer sauce. Dead simple. I did one
of these on my little--. We do these little
live, we're doing one tonight. We do the little
webcasts. Two years ago, it would cost about
a hundred grand and satellites and 30 people
to do it.
And now, we do it with a couple of dudes,
a couple of phones, a computer, and out it
goes. So, we're gonna do it. We did it the
other day. It's very simple. It's an uncooked
pasta sauce. So, we're gonna crack on with
that. How's it going?
>>Maria: Almost there.
>>Jamie Oliver: OK. Now, before we do this,
let me just think. While we're doing that,
we're gonna knead it. Get it a bit firmer.
>>Male Helper: Handle's come off.
>>Jamie Oliver: This?
>>Maria: No, no, it's fine.
>>Jamie Oliver: Oh, the end off. That's all
right. What I'm gonna do is I'm gonna take--.
Is there any single girls in the audience?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: Single girls.
[laughter]
Any single girls in the audience?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Here.
>>Jamie Oliver: OK. Blonde lady, please stand
up. What's your name?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #1: Stephanie.
>>Jamie Oliver: Stephanie. Please come forth.
Give a round of applause to Stephanie.
[applause]
Now, don't be scared. I'll look after you.
Where did you come from?
>>Stephanie: Ireland.
>>Jamie Oliver: Lovely. Where abouts?
>>Stephanie: [inaudible].
>>Jamie Oliver: Lovely. Is that north or south,
excuse my ignorance?
>>Stephanie: South.
>>Jamie Oliver: South. Lovely. Sit down. Any
single men in the audience?
>>Audience: Woo!
>>Jamie Oliver: She's lovely. She's very foxy.
You're a chef, mate. Best to you. Any single
men coming? We got one here. Anyone else?
Anyone else?
[laughter]
You can't be the only single man.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #3: He's the only one.
[laughter]
>>Jamie Oliver: Are you straight? OK. Up you
come.
[audience cheers]
Nice to meet you. What's your name?
>>Glenn: Glenn.
>>Jamie Oliver: Glenn? Sit down. Make yourself
known over there. We've got wine coming.
[laughter]
Don't you worry. We'll be all right. Now,
I'll tell you what we'll do while these guys--.
How's it going?
>>Male Helper: It looks better.
>>Maria: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: Beautiful. Lovely. Just put
a little flour in it as it comes out as well.
That's nice. Have we got those cherries, lovely
Christina Scarabucci? Oh, cherry tomato. That's
where we got it wrong. Don't worry.
OK. So what we're gonna do is we're gonna
make these guys a little dish, OK? I'm gonna
give them a quick dish while I muck about
with this pasta. It's a scallop dish. I'm
just gonna get rid of this pan here. Sorry.
We've got an induction up here though, chef.
You might have to help me with this one. Here
we go.
It's working, I think. And I press--. No.
Could you just help me with that. I'm not
very good with induction. I like gas and fire.
I'm not very good on technology. OK, so we
have pasta here.
>>Maria: Yes.
>>Jamie Oliver: Well done. That's on. So,
we're gonna make these lovely people a little
dish. You like scallops?
>>Stephanie: Yes.
>>Jamie Oliver: Nice. We got some champagne
there. We got some wine. So this is a lovely,
quick little dish. I don't mean to make you
guys feel awkward. Don't worry about us lot.
Do you know what I mean?
[laughter]
So, we got a pan getting nice and hot. We
got two things happening right now. We got
some--
[laughter]
That's it. Cheers. I wish we had some romantic
music. So, darling, will you come over here?
>>Maria: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: What we're gonna do, if you
can get a pair of tongs and just get some
olive oil in here. And just add some pancetta,
or smoky bacon go in there. About three rashers
would be lovely. I wanna get some beautiful
scallops here.
I don't have a corer. I'm just gonna score
them halfway down in a criss-cross. OK? Now
this is for two reasons: to take on seasoning,
to cook quicker, but also to look beautiful
as well. So, I wanna take those and then--.
Best friends, scallops are sweet and delicious.
You could do the same dish with little pieces
of monkfish, exactly the same.
You could do the same thing with prawns. I'm
just gonna cook them with some smoky bacon,
or as you call it, pancetta. So we're go in
with the bacon. We got the olive oil. We're
hoping that our induction pot actually works.
>>Maria: That's three.
>>Jamie Oliver: Three. Beautiful. Three scallops.
Three bits of bacon. Now, lentils. Lentils
is a funny one. You can take them dry. You
don't have to soak them. You can put them
in a pan. You can cook them in about 15 to
20 minutes.
Now, lentils aren't the sexiest thing in the
world. People get a bit miserable, boring.
All you do is just put a little cherry tomato
in there. Cover it with water. When they're
nice and soft and cooked, then the flavoring
begins, OK? So, what we're gonna do with this
is we're gonna dress it almost like salad.
So we're gonna put in here some olive oil,
lemon juice, and a load of chopped herbs.
That's not so safe. We're gonna bring that
back up to the heat. You can see the bacon
here. It's just getting nice and crispy. Hopefully,
you guys are starting to smell stuff in a
little bit. That's on full whack. When I first
started, well, a long time ago when I was
at college at Westminster, I was 18. The Roux
Brothers came and did a demonstration the
first year these were invented.
So, this is microwaves, not gas. And the Roux
Brothers were the most famous chefs in the
country at that time. And they started to
cook and they burnt every dish.
[laughter]
And I feel for them because all these years
later, I still can't get me head around it.
'Cause you can't see it. That's the beautiful
thing about fire. So darling, what we're gonna
do is as soon as that starts getting some
color, we're gonna season up these scallops.
Now, I'm gonna use lemons here. A little bit
underrated in the sense that we always chuck
the skins away. So, if you can just do a little
flick of the lemon zest like that.
>>Maria: There?
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah, just from a height.
We're gonna season it also with some sea salt,
Maldon sea salt. Anyone from Essex here?
>>Audience: Yay.
>>Jamie Oliver: OK. It's just us then, darling.
[laughter]
The Maldon sea salt from Essex. And we're
turning the bacon over. It's starting to take
on some color. Now, scallops, they only need
literally three minutes cooking. So, that's
enough, Sweetheart. But they got beautiful
flavor in that zest.
So, what we're gonna do is we're gonna angle--you
can see it just taking on color. I'm gonna
angle the fat down this side and we're gonna
put the scallops, cut side down first in that
lovely fat there, the smoky bacon fat.
>>Maria: Like this?
>>Male Presenter: Jamie, so we've got a couple
questions--
>>Jamie Oliver: Go for it.
>>Male Presenter: from the other end of the
telly. Can I ask you as we're going?
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah, go to it.
>>Male Presenter: Somebody from Dublin, Graine
in Dublin said, what do you think we should
keep in our kitchens to make tasty, healthy
meals over the weekend? We get lots of lovely,
tasty meals here in the week.
>>Jamie Oliver: Well, I think to be honest,
growing herbs wherever you live is wicked.
Olive oil, lemon juice brings everything to
life, whether it's a simple piece of fish,
batter it out. A simple cooked bit of chargrilled
in a griddle pan, chicken. So I mean for me,
herbs, olive oil, and lemon juice and chili
are my life.
>>Male Presenter: That's it.
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah, well it's they're so
good for you. If you have herbs in your life,
you will be a healthier person. They all do
different things, but it's incredibly good
for you. Some help you digest.
Some are great for your liver. Some help you
thin your blood or speed up your endorphins.
Chili’s speed up your metabolism by 25%
for about two hours after. So, great thing
to burn out the energy, but also, it does
release endorphins, though you can kind of
get high on it.
[laughter]
Which--
>>Maria: I think the big one is--
>>Jamie Oliver: Beautiful. OK. So now, just
control this. You can see here, just turn
that one over again, too. Just keep giving
it some love. This is hot. We're gonna put
some olive oil in here. Now, olive oil.
Good olive oil, not really for cooking, but
for finishing, dressings. When you finish
a pasta dish or a soup or a stew, just a little
bit goes in like this. We're gonna put in
some lemon juice like that. So, we're just
gonna treat this like a salad almost, but
it's getting warm. And then we're gonna feed
our romantic couple over here. You can see
it's getting very involved.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: Why did you pick him?
>>Jamie Oliver: To be honest, mate, he was
my only choice, but you know. You never know.
We could start a beautiful thing here.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: So, we're gonna go in with
some basil like that. Stir it in. The scallops
are looking good, my darling. Let's get our
plate. Where is our plate? We're gonna go
for a little bit of this. We have a little
taste.
>>Maria: OK.
>>Jamie Oliver: You can take those off the
heat now, Sweetheart.
>>Maria: Do you want those on the plate?
>>Jamie Oliver: Not quite yet, Sweetheart.
So we're gonna just mix this up.
>>Maria: I don't know what to do with this.
>>Jamie Oliver: You're all right. Yeah. Just
turn it off.
>>Maria: OK.
>>Jamie Oliver: There you go. We have a little
taste. And you wanna balance the olive oil,
salt and pepper, a little mint I think I put
in there as well, herbs. Vinegar is really
good, actually. Vinegar and lentils is just
a little sweet. It makes all the difference.
I'm just gonna chop it up. And then we'll
serve this up. Nice thing to make the len--.
I always feel it's a bit of a link missing
with the lentils and the thing that really
makes a difference is a little bit of yogurt,
or crème fraiche. So, that for me. A little
bit like with rice is a beautiful thing. So,
I'm just gonna serve the lentils in here.
Nice to put things like purple basil, if you've
got it. Stuff like, you can chop roquette
in there as well. We're gonna go for our scallops.
Here. Very nice. Put that on top like that.
And our bacon. So what was, any more questions
you got from your guys?
>>Male Presenter: Yeah, sorry. Your campaign
in America had started to become quite successful.
What can people who are around the world do
to join that campaign for example, against
sales of flavored milk and some of the things
you've been campaigning against?
>>Jamie Oliver: Look, man. I mean, here lies
the thing. I have a really weird job. I have
a really weird job. I mean basically, like
I said, I'm a storyteller on one hand. I write
books, but really the TV bit is a story-telling.
So, in my profession, people come to me and
give me stories and tell me about things that
are right and wrong, whether it's Green Peace
or just regular people or kids or whatever.
And then it's my job to go out and let everyone
know. And then the thing is we created this
genre of the, a new genre, really, which is
campaigning TV.
And I think it's really important these days.
I mean, creating TV that scares politicians
to watch their back and do a good job. And
so much slips through the net. So, stuff like
what we did in America, it's a really weird
one 'cause it was over two and a half months
of hell. And everything went wrong. But the
story became about lack of transparency and
not being at--
[laughter]
Good Lord. Things are looking up over here.
It became about lack of transparency, but
of course, I know deep down that if I'm telling
a good story, when it goes on TV it all kicks
off. And it did because the guy that ran the
food, the local schools, he was an idiot.
Got fired, which is good. And here you go,
my love. So we've got some scallops. This
is to share.
>>Stephanie: Thank you.
>>Jamie Oliver: So we got the first dish.
Scallops and lentils, crispy bacon, a little
creme fraiche. But it did start making--.
I mean, you should see the food in these schools.
It's terrible. And it's actually worse than
it was in England seven years ago. And we're
in transition, strangely, but--.
>>Male Presenter: So how can people like Darrin
in Cambridge, Massachusetts get involved?
How can people over here get involved in the
campaign?
>>Jamie Oliver: Well, the thing to do really,
I mean that's where the web is great. Go to
thefoodrevolution.com and sign the petition.
I'm trying to get it to a million before I
take it to the White House. So, we've got
just over 700, 000 . And we need, how many
employees you got at Google?
>>Male Presenter: About fifteen hundred in
London.
>>Jamie Oliver: Fifteen hundred?
>>Male Presenter: Fifteen hundred? About six
hundred in here, I think.
>>Jamie Oliver: Well if you can get five,
ten of your mates to sign the petition, we'd
get well on the way towards that end.
>>Male Presenter: Who's up for that?
[audience cheers]
>>Jamie Oliver: I mean it's all about stirring
the pot, really. It's all about--. I think
the thing that I've tried to do in England
and America is sort of prove that--and it's
what you do at Google, actually--is like,
if you've got, if you're promoting healthy
food, healthy life, then you can learn you
can be productive.
You can get on in life. Cool. So we've got
our first dish over here. You all right?
>>Stephanie: Yes.
>>Jamie Oliver: You've got the champ and the
white wine. We should do the pasta, really,
shouldn't we?
>>Maria: Yes.
>>Jamie Oliver: 'Cause I'm sort of going well
out of order here. So, we have some pasta.
I wanna put that water back on. Thank you
very much. I find myself going around the
world always cooking in other people's kitchens,
which is always challenging to know where
everything is.
You know in your own kitchen you're like.
But let's get rid of this. OK. I wanna show
you an uncooked pasta sauce. So lovely Christina,
if I may.
>>Male Presenter: Jamie, while you're doing
that, people from the room have got some questions.
If you want to ask Jamie a question, then
there's a mic in the center, there. If anybody's
brave enough to step up and--
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah, don't be afraid.
>>Male Presenter: have a go while you're doing
that. Some of us are parents, Jamie. You've
got kids.
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: What do you do to get your
kids to think about eating healthily and eating
sensibly?
>>Jamie Oliver: Well, nothing really. It's
just a natural part of what we do. We try
and grow a few things. And they react really
well to that. We try and sit down at least
twice a week as a whole family. And that is
profoundly important.
You don't even have to buy anything. Just
walking your kid through a farmer's market
twice a month for 20 minutes will make a profound
difference by the time that kid gets to 18.
I mean, what you've got to understand from
my perspective, 'cause I don't know how much
of the work you know that I do, but I don't
just go on talking about stuff.
I'm in people's homes of all walks of life
in different countries. And the stuff that's
really killing people, the stuff that's making
people lose their dad at like, 40, and there's
a kid with no dad, which is very common, the
biggest killer in America and England is diet-related
disease. And put it into perspective, 8% of
America die through homicide or gun crime.
And over 60% are these diet-related disease.
So, the thing is if you think about the resources
that the police have and then we can't even
get a decent meal in a school. So, that's
the way I see the world. So, I suppose what
I'm trying to say is little thing--. As a
parent, you don't have to do big grand things,
but I think enjoy food, do little things often,
go down a farmer's market, let them choose.
Let the kids make decisions. Growing stuff,
mate, I've never ever met a kid from anywhere
that if you teach him how to grow something
they won't try it. So, just have fun with
it basically.
>>Male Presenter: And you make your kids do
all the pasta twirly things and all that?
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah. Daisy does. Poppy's
not so interested. She's a bit of a bookworm,
but Daisy's all over it. I mean, she's eight
years old and she can do poached eggs, fried
eggs, scrambled egg. She's on omelets. She's
like making smoothies. She's doing cappuccino
and the frothing.
[laughter]
And she's really cheap labor. She don't cost
anything.
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: I'm going to go home and
have a word.
[Jamie Oliver laughs]
>>Jamie Oliver: My darling, please.
>>Maria: Yes.
>>Jamie Oliver: So this is just Sicilian pasta
that I learned. If we just take a little of
the, just long strokes of the lemon. So, it's
lemon juice, a little lemon zest, mind your
fingers, Sweetpea.
>>Maria: I love it.
[laughter]
>>Jamie Oliver: I'm gonna--. We don't want
any finger in there. What you can do--you
don't have to--but just what I love about
herbs is you can take literally four or five
leaves, put it in a pestle and mortar, and
the flavor that comes out of that is incredible.
So, a pinch of salt and a little bashing of
the basil. Sorry, I know you're eating, but
just bash that up for me, mate. Get that to
a paste. A bit of delegation going on here.
And then what we're gonna do is balance parmesan
and olive oil. So, that's fine, sweetheart.
If I can take that off of you.
>>Maria: Sure.
>>Jamie Oliver: If you could pour olive oil
in there.
>>Maria: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: This is very good. Extra virgin
olive oil. If any of you are confused about
olive oil, a lot of people are. So, OK. You
generally get what you pay for. But there's
nothing wrong with the cheap stuff.
The cheap stuff will be highly, highly filtered,
which means you probably can cook with it,
not too bad, but not too hot for wok frying
but for cooking off prawns or stuff like that.
Anything over a tenner is very good. Anything
cold pressed and over a tenner is gonna be
pretty damn good olive oil. It's only good
for a year. Sorry.
It's only at its best for about eight months
and then it starts to deplete. And really,
you use really good oil as an ingredient,
not an oil. So, in my house I'll have a cheap
oil for doing light cooking. I'll have like
a sunflower oil or a groundnut oil for like,
wok frying or high-heat cooking. And then
the kick ass stuff, I use little by little
for finishing things like this dish.
So, I'm gonna squeeze in the lemon juice like
that. How's your bashing going? That's a very
delicate way of doing it. Give it a good old
rattling, mate. Go on. Give it a good old
bashing. That looks a bit dodgy, but there's--.
[laughter]
I think I'll take that away from you now.
It is only your first date after all.
[laughter]
Bless. Colorful lot here at Google. OK. Now
look. What I love is that tiny bit of basil
is gonna make dramatic change to this dish.
So, my Italian princess, if you can come over
here.
>>Maria: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: We're gonna put in a little
handful of parmesan cheese, freshly grated.
I wouldn't buy the pre-grated stuff. Always
get the blocks. Olive oil in. And we're making
a lemon, basil, parmesan, and good olive oil
slurry, right?
And then I'll come back and show you how it's
gonna be good. Now hopefully, this is gonna
come--.
>>Male Presenter: I've got a bit of a spiky
question from Dublin for you, Jamie, if you
don't mind. Spiky question. This is from my
friend Pendo. She says, "I bought your book
and made a couple of lovely meals. They're
really nice, but I find the title a bit misleading."
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: "Neither meal took the promised
30 minutes. Did you ever consider the less
catchy '30-Minute Meals Only if You've Got
a Food Processor' title?"
>>Maria: Hahaha
[crowd laughter]
>>Jamie Oliver: Umm.
[laughter]
Tell her to read the bloody introduction.
>>Male Presenter: Yeah, OK.
[laughter]
>>Jamie Oliver: No.
>>Male Presenter: There you go, Pendo.
>>Jamie Oliver: Hello, my friend.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: I have a question
about buying stuff. For example, you mentioned
Tesco before and this oh, 2% of all, 20% of
all sales come from Tesco.
>>Jamie Oliver: Yes.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: So I wonder, and
I have a friend who is buying stuff only like
from farmer's markets and very like organic
stuff. How is--. What's your opinion on buying
let's say, vegetables and natural stuff, not
processed stuff?
But from Tesco, from Sainsbury's, from the
normal supermarkets. Is it, should it, because
I cannot go to a farmer's market every Saturday.
It would take up too much of my time. So,
is it OK to buy vegetables at--?
>>Jamie Oliver: Of course, especially here
in England. I think compared to many countries,
there's been a lot changing in the last five
years. So, obviously buying British is great,
but general welfare chicken, pork, is way
in excess of most countries.
And loads of people would debate that, but
I'm a geek and I know it and I study it. Like,
it's pretty damn high. So, I mean for me personally,
I shop in a supermarket. I get me every day
bits and pieces and I also go some farmer's
markets as well. And I think it's nice to
balance stuff and then using internet stuff
that's convenient, having stuff delivered.
So I think it's a balance of all those things.
I mean, look. If you live out in the country
and you got a local butcher and stuff, use
them, of course. But I think for modern day
busy city people, it's quite nice to do a
bit of everything. And just balance it up.
But at the end of the day, generally if you
go to a supermarket, there's always a choice--fairly
high welfare and everyday basic stuff.
So, you can buy in to whatever you can afford
or whatever you're into, really. But I mean,
organics is really important but I think people
confuse organics as a way of producing food,
not a standard. Yeah, it is a standard, but
it's really about not spraying it with any
pesticides and bits and pieces like that.
And if it's an animal, it'll be twice as old
by the time it gets, you know.
So, it does cost more. So, a lot of people
do resent it, but I think for me personally,
I love cooking at that level and being geeky
and it's all wild fish and everything's perfect.
But the real, my job actually, is working
with people that have only got 50 Quid to
spend on food a week for a family of four
or less. And so the question is what do you
give to them?
So really, it's turned into a bunch of ingredients
into some dinner. And it's a lot of ground
meat and mincemeat and root vegetables and
trying to make classic things, like bolognaises
and lasagnas and stuff that people like. So,
that's the priority. I mean, I think we have
these centers around England called the Ministry
of Food Centres.
We got about six. And we're gonna have fifteen
in Australia. We got two in the States and
counting. And basically, it's free cooking
lessons for anyone that wants to go there.
But it's really basic stuff that we're teaching
because I guess at the end of the day, most
parents weren't taught to cook at school and
they're both working. So, that's what we're
trying to do, really.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #4: Thank you.
>>Jamie Oliver: Cheers mate. Any more questions,
brother?
>>Male Presenter: Any more questions from
the floor? So, I've got a question. We were
involved with you on the Dream Teachers project,
right? And it was really inspiring and we
had a whole bunch of teachers submit--
>>Jamie Oliver: Oh, yeah.
>>Male Presenter: videos on YouTube and win
prizes, which is great. What did you learn
from that process? It seemed like a big journey
for you.
>>Jamie Oliver: Dream School?
>>Male Presenter: Yeah.
>>Jamie Oliver: I don't know what's going
on with this pasta, sorry. I'm gonna have
to fix this. Dream School for me was brilliant.
It was like, for me, it was an opportunity
to sort of like, if you had a magic wand,
what would you do at school?
If you didn't have any rules, if you could
make up the rules, what would you do at school?
And that, of course, we had celebrity Olympic
gold medalists and stuff teaching the lessons
and bits and pieces like that. But it was
an opportunity.
Most of the teachers had done badly at school.
But what was amazing was, and I think the
reason the program was valid, was that over
50% of all British kids graduate school with
not five GCSEs of grade C or above. And therefore,
they can't go into university and they can't
go in at higher education.
So, I guess what the show was saying was half
of it were not working. So, shortly we should
be teaching these kids a bit differently.
So, it was a bit controversial at times. Everyone
thought we were there to knock the teachers,
but we weren't. It was really about saying,
"Is there another way?" And certainly, personally,
I learned I think just as much as the students
did.
>>Male Presenter: So you think there is another
way of having done that?
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah. I definitely--. I love
the argument about what is education. What
is it? What's the point of it? What is it
there to do? So, all right. We've got maths
and English and it's really, really important.
But like I know that if you don't do your
geography homework, I know you're not, you
ain't gonna die young, but I know if you don't
learn about food, where it comes from, what
it does to your body, you will die young.
Because at the moment, we got the first generation
of kids that are gonna die at a younger age
than their parents.
So, I guess I'm biased because I think the
sport thing and the food education thing,
I think should be in every single school,
obviously. But I'm gonna attempt to cook this
pasta. There's some that we did earlier that
I'm gonna unwind here. This is a tagliolini
. So, oh is that boiling again? I do apologize
everyone.
I'm a bit caught out on this technology. Boil
please. So we're gonna--. No. I think we're
fine. Are you guys? Oh, you cleaned that off,
didn't ya? My God. All right. Let's do the
next one. Me and my Italian darling, we are
gonna make this very simple pasta. If any
of you guys wanna ask any more questions,
please come up to the mic. You can ask anything
you like. There's nothing I won't answer.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: I had a quick question.
>>Jamie Oliver: Go for it, brother.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: So Ferran Adria
is taking 18 months off Sabbatical to inspire
himself with cooking. Have you ever taken
Sabbaticals and gone and traveled the world
to find really out-there ingredients and different
ways of cooking?
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah.
>>MALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #5: So can you just
talk about some sort of travel experiences
that you've had with cooking?
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah, sure. Well, I travel
a lot. And I meet a lot of amazing people
and I'm always learning. I'd love to take
a Sabbatical. It'd be really nice. I will
take a Sabbatical in a couple of years. But
I'm in a kind of--.
I have a funny job. I'm responsible for 6000
staff and 20 restaurants and charities and
all of their mortgages and their families,
and we're in a recession. And I think that's
important right now, you know? And you know
as well, and I'm positive it's the same with
you guys, but I'm blessed. I feel like I've
made good decisions over the last ten years.
I've surrounded myself by clever, beautiful
people that have got my back. And when I'm
in front of my guys, I'm inspired. We bang
ideas around and we sort of like, come back.
And then we bang other things around and we
have a very creative job, whether it's building
restaurants-- What does it look like? What's
on the floor?
What's the experience? How do we greet? What
is the food? What's the price? What's the
vibe? Or, write in a book, "How did he design
it?" What's the mentality behind it, or documentaries.
And some of my best work that I do on TV,
I hate making. The documentaries is seriously
like a colonic irrigation. It's terrible.
[laughter]
But then I do the cooking shows, which is
just beautiful and enjoy. And next week, we're
doing a Feastival, which is on Clapham Common,
which is basically bringing music and all
the chefs of London and demonstrations together.
And just have a big old party. So, I'm very
inspired. But I would one day love--. I pressed
something. What did I do wrong though? What
did I do? It's got a problem with me. But
I would love to do--. I actually was talking
to him about his Sabbatical. And I think sometimes,
you start off so simple and then it goes crazy,
and look--.
I'm 36 years old. I started my first employee
when I was 20. And I got six thousand staff
now, last time I counted. Like, you think,
"Shit. What happened?" And I'm happy. But
like, simple is nice. Do you know what I mean?
And even like Google, come on. I would like
to have that time out. I don't know when.
I want to go to Argentina.
I wanna go to Asia. I wanna go to Timbuk-bloody-tu.
And I love people. I love people. No matter
where I go in the world, I always find great
food, even if there's lots of bad food. I'll
always find the good stuff. So, let's finish
this pasta. OK, the pasta is gonna go in.
We're gonna cook it.
There was nothing wrong with yours, apart
from it did stick together, which was probably
my fault 'cause I'm probably not leading the
best charge at the moment, but I'm trying
my best. I'm trying my best. So, the pasta's
gone in. It'll only take hardly any time at
all to cook. And we're gonna mix it up. Our
romantic couple here, you can see, is going
very, very well.
[laughter]
We're gonna serve it up. You can share. Here
we go. And just after, once we're done, we'll
carry on doing questions and bits and pieces
like that. After we've done that, I'm gonna
knock out. I'm gonna be doing mushrooms, beautiful
wild mushrooms, are the best way to cook mushrooms
that can go off in any way, whether it's risotto,
in bruschetta or in quiches.
It's the ultimate way I cook mushrooms And
the perfect steak. So if you wanna hang around
for that, you're more than welcome. It's only
gonna last 30 minutes, so, 'cause it's live.
So, I've gotta pull my finger out. So things
better work. But we'll have a little--. It
stopped working again. Oh dear. See?
>>Male Presenter: Do you have another question
while you're--
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #6: Sure. What's
your favorite food memory? The last thing
you ate that you thought, "Oh, my God, this
is absurd."
>>Jamie Oliver: OK. The last thing I did that
was like, uniquely like that, OK. We had this
bouncing around. We were in Yorkshire, where
they invented the Yorkshire pudding. And we
were making it with various people and it
was lovely. And if you look at Yorkshire pudding,
it's very similar to a blini or a pancake
batter.
And I'm thinking blini. And I was thinking,
"Smoked fish, smoked salmon." And then I made
this very, very simple--. And it sounds ultra-humble
and it is, but it's like, smoked trout, lemon
juice, cream cheese, some light herbs. And
so, smoky, sour, and creamy. And then I did
these little mini Yorkshire puddings that
I just like, straight out of the oven, big
and fluffy and then just used it like little--.
Had the two together. Basically, a pot of
smoked fish pate and these lovely Yorkshire
puddings. And I went, "Oh my God, this is
amazing." And I started--. And everyone was
like, "Wow." And it's really funny. And I
had to, oh yeah. We had grated horseradish
with the smoked fish. It was unbelievable.
But I thought, "Why have I never tried that
before?"
But it's nice when you give it to other people
and you can see in their eyes as well. It's
good. But to be honest, the way things work,
it's like that all the time. We're cooking
every--. I mean, I'm still cooking every single
day. And we're testing things every single
day. So, with the pasta, we'll go into our
parmesan, into our sauce here. This is probably
the worst pasta I've ever cooked in my life.
[laughter]
I do apologize. This is the beauty of cooking
not on gas.
>>Male Presenter: So, Jamie. Did you ever
have a bad day where it doesn't work out on
you?
>>Jamie Oliver: Like today, yeah.
[laughter]
Yeah. Not too often, but that is really fuckin'
horrible.
[laughter]
God bless. You're gonna get the idea, but
use your imagination, all right?
[laughter]
My God. I'm with an Italian as well.
>>Maria: Doesn't look good.
>>Jamie Oliver: Here we go.
[laughter]
This is not good.
>>Maria: Is that pasta?
>>Jamie Oliver: No. It's fuckin' horrible.
OK. Let's just pretend that never happened.
Bless you. Tuck in. Try not to vomit. The
sauce is very fresh.
[applause]
I promise the next bit will work. If I can
get that pan to work. Yes, but I think the
worst thing, I've been cooking a lot in wood
ovens in the last year and a half. And when
you get it wrong in a wood oven, you really
screw things up. Not just on induction hobs.
>>Male Presenter: What? Does the oven catch
light?
>>Jamie Oliver: You just--. When you've spent
seven hours slow-cooking like a lovely shoulder
of pork or something like that, and then you
don't look at it for a second and you just
nuke it, then there's nothing savable at all.
It's a nightmare.
>>Male Presenter: That's a bad day.
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: I think we've got another
question here. We've got about another five
minutes to go, so--.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #7: If you could
have one tip, for example, you have friends
that love McDonald's and all the unhealthy
stuff and everything massively with sauces
and everything, how would you excite people
like that to go into the healthy route?
>>Jamie Oliver: To be honest, I think what
I try to do when I did 20-Minute Meals app,
was like--. That was a really interesting
time for me because we had the shopping list
bit and we also had the recipe where you have
the step by step pictures and the little tutorials
and if there was any techniques, there was
a little video.
And for me, that was the ultimate actually.
It was like an app is better than a book because
it's got all the extra bits that you could
never put in a book. So, that was interesting
for me because most of the people that bought
it, most of them, had never bought a book
before. So, it was a new audience. But also,
it was amazing seeing people shopping with
it and then Twittering about it.
And so, I think phones are really great for
that. And we're on Android now. So--
>>Male Presenter: Thank God for that.
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah. We got there. We got
there in the end.
[applause]
>>Male Presenter: Will you make them with
the Android here? That's where we cook.
>>Jamie Oliver: Yes. Well I think just making
things simple. I mean, I love when they work,
like the pan or the griddle pan or the wok,
is brilliant--really, really good. And I think
you can have little four, five ingredient
dishes, like I said, using the chili and the
herbs and citrus and olive oil.
That's the bedrock of everything I do. Yes,
darling?
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #8: Hi Jamie.
>>Jamie Oliver: Hi, darling.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #8: I'd like to make
a lot of your pasta dishes, but I'm gluten
intolerant. Do you have any tips for making
gluten-free pasta, or would you just avoid
it altogether?
>>Jamie Oliver: Umm, no. What you can do is
there's parts of Italy--I don't know if you've
seen it before--where they make pasta out
of chestnut flour, or even polenta. It's not
very common, but they do do it.
And you get firmer dough. And literally, you
just go and get finely ground polenta or maize
and you mix it with water. You make a tight
dough and you get one of those little pasta
rollers. And you make the sheet and you can
cut it up. It's not the same as regular pasta.
It's more robust. But at the end of the day,
it's still beautiful and it can carry lovely
sauces and stuff like that.
Actually, I'll tell you what. I think I have--.
Come up here, darling. And I'm gonna give
you a present.
>>Audience: Aww.
>>Jamie Oliver: We have a pasta machine here.
Which you can have.
[applause]
So, good luck.
>>Male Presenter: Gotta ask good questions.
How about that?
>>Maria: That was nice.
>>Jamie Oliver: Yeah. They're still eating,
there.
>>Maria: Yeah.
>>Male Presenter: Anybody else have questions?
I've got a question for Glenn. How's the meal,
Glenn? How's it going?
>>Glenn: Absolutely pucca .
>>Jamie Oliver: Oh my God.
[laughter]
>>Glenn: You want more? You want more?
>>Jamie Oliver: How's your romantic date going?
I don't know what that means. Bless.
>>Male Presenter: All right. We got another
question.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #9: Hi, Jamie.
>>Jamie Oliver: Hi, darling.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #9: Apart from your
own restaurants, what's your favorite place
to eat out in London?
>>Jamie Oliver: Well obviously, I worked for
many, many years in The River Café . I love
that. Places like Moro in Exmouth Market I
love, but I used to work with those guys,
too. Places like Trullo in Islington, with
that--.
[clapping]
Bless you. That's one of my ex-students, so
I'm biased there as well. We're all kind of
from the same family. But it's nice. Like
with Trullo, like Tim that runs it. He was
out in our first group of students from Fifteens.
So, it's nice. It's our tenth-year anniversary
next year and it's really nice that the first-year
students are like, they're smashing it now.
They're doing their thing and they're doing
a great job. So, it's kind of a nice time.
Where else do I love, love, love? Bizarrely,
I don't really get to go out much in London
'cause I'm always working, really. I'm a veteran
of other countries when I have to go somewhere.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #9: Do you tend to
cook at home a lot?
>>Jamie Oliver: Always. Yeah. My missus don't
really cook at home. It's me. And people don't
believe me, but it's true. She really doesn't
cook for me. She's done a few stews. And they're
really not good.
[laughter]
But they're probably better than that pasta,
so you know. She's winning today.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #9: OK. Thank you.
>>Male Presenter: OK. Next question.
>>Jamie Oliver: Pleasure.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #10: First, a comment.
So, I'm American and I have a confession.
My favorite pancake, American pancake recipe,
is yours.
>>Jamie Oliver: Ahh.
>>FEMALE AUDIENCE MEMBER #10: And so, my question
is totally unrelated. I'm just wondering what
your least favorite food is.
>>Jamie Oliver: My least favorite. Well, I'm
not really into genitals.
[laughter]
I have, in your country, I have taken part
in some Rocky Mountain Oysters. Bullocks,
bullocks. Yeah.
[laughter]
It wasn't the best moment of my life. I've
been offered lots of other genitals, which
I declined. In Japan, cod semen wasn't my
best moment. And I did swallow.
[laughter]
What was really--. What was really--. I mean,
I love Japan. I worked there for three years
and I enjoy the food so much. But I'd had
no meat for a long time. And there's this
little dude on this little grill and, "Oh,
God. He's got chicken. He's got chicken. Yeah!
Shambone!"
And he's doing a little thing. And I haven't
had any meat for like two weeks. And he just
gave, and you know how they do. They give
you this beautiful perfect little thing and
they give it to you. And I just banged it
in my mouth and it just exploded and I went,
"Oh, it's not chicken. What is it?" [imitates
food seller's foreign language]
It's cod semen. I'm like, "Ahh."
[laughter]
Didn't even have a choice. It was gone by
then. Do you wish you'd never asked that question?
Yeah.
>>Male Presenter:Just puts a downer on the
whole thing. So, how many people are feeling
inspired by Jamie's presence here today? Yay.
[applause]
There's an opportunity, as usual, to get involved
in this wellness Optimize Your Life program.
So, if you wanna be a champion, don't forget
to email Ollie, who's sitting in the front
here, have a wave at Google.
And you can become a wellness champion. I
don't really know what that means, but it
sounds inspiring. Hopefully, we can do that.
Jamie,I think we're nearly out of time; I'm
sorry. Is there anything else you wanted to
say?
>>Jamie: What I want to say is that thanks
for having me. I know it's been a bit kick-bullocks
scrambled, but thank you so much. It's a real
pleasure. Anything, I mean, I think the one
thing for me that I'm passionate about is
whether it's food--.
Well, as far as food is concerned, it's a
massively. The only thing worth more than
petrol is food. And the only thing affecting
our world around us in a big, big way is food
as well. And I think you might not see it
in front of you, but all of us have the opportunity
to have an opinion and stir the pot. And now
is a really, really important time, and the
next 15 years.
So, I don't know what I'm saying, really,
apart from like, just because you're one person,
doesn't mean you can't get involved. It doesn't
mean you can't stir the petition. It doesn't
mean you can't get with another Mum or another
Dad at school and find out where stuff comes
from that's going in your kid every day.
And just mix it up, really. So, that's it,
really. But I do want to do one thing. 'Cause
I've got a present for our Italian guest,
here. A little hamper. And I've got a hamper
of nice, beautiful things for you.
>>Maria: Really? Ahhh
[applause]
I've also--. This is a voucher to get some
proper food, and cooked for you to take with
one of your loved ones.
>>Maria: Thank you.
>>Jamie Oliver: Wherever they come from.
>>Maria: Thanks. That's so sweet.
>>Jamie Oliver: Take care. Thank you very
much. Thanks for your help. Bless you. Thank
you, you two. Now, I think we've got something
in. What have we got here? We got a box. I've
got a pasta machine here. You're gonna have
a mug. But that doesn't mean anything. And
there's a pasta machine for you, darling.
Lovely to meet you.
>>Male Presenter: And Jamie, we can't let
you go empty handed. Thank you very, very
much for coming today. It's been fantastic
to have Jamie here, hasn't it?
[applause]
>>Jamie Oliver: Thank you very much. Cheers
mate.
>>Male Presenter: We've got a little gift
for you. We've got some gifts.
>>Jamie Oliver: It's a water flask for specimens.
>>Male Presenter: That's for testing you're
properly hydrated.
>>Jamie Oliver: Is it one of those suction
things?
[laughter]
>>Male Presenter: We've got some Chrome bean
bags for your two at home. Some Google bean
bags.
>>Jamie: Bless you!
>>Male Presenter: They're gonna be delivered
to your house. And we got some little Androids
for your little Androids.
>>Jamie Oliver: Thank you. Oh, yes. Four children
I've got. My God. Ah, thank you very much.
>>Male Presenter: Ladies and gentlemen, thank
you very much. Jamie Oliver!
[applause]
>>Jamie Oliver: Bless you, Thank you very
much guys.
[applause]